[Music]
all right okay yeah okay where'd you
grow up where are you from originally i
grew up in south carolina i was born in
arizona i left when i was 20 months and
i was in south carolina until i turned
21 moved arizona and then 22 to 26 in
cali
how did you describe your childhood you
had both mom and dad uh i had my mom my
dad was in and out of the picture he was
in prison or jail a lot
childhood was all right i mean i got
into a lot of trouble
uh my mom
didn't wanting troublemakers she was
always wanting me to do good but i was
just hard-headed didn't like to listen
and like to do whatever i was told not
to do it was more fun that way you make
it through high school uh no i got
expelled permanently halfway through my
ninth grade year
yeah that was a very interesting time a
friend of mine said that i was saying
something that i had said in the past
but he said that i was saying it again
and because that i got expelled what was
it you were saying uh i had threatened
to shoot a teacher in the face with a
double-barrelled shot-off shotgun
because of
the child and she pissed me off and
the first time i did it they they told
me that i couldn't bring a backpack back
to school
and that i had to be monitored by the
sro all the time and then
the only reason they didn't arrest me
was because i didn't have the gun and
because i they said i was emotionally
disturbed i didn't know how to properly
display my emotions
and then i guess a friend thought that i
was saying it again and went and
snitched on me and they permanently
expelled me from there i wasn't allowed
back on any greenville school greenville
county school property without reporting
straight to the sro otherwise i'd be
arrested on the spot
so where'd you go where'd your life go
after that
uh after that my mom pretty much told me
if you're under my roof you're going to
work or you're going to school so i went
to a metal fabrication shop working with
my step dad when i was 16
and then after that i went to a military
school in a crowded side military
program and lived on base for five and a
half months
yeah it was fun how was military school
um well to say the least i got strong
because i'm hardheaded and i don't like
to listen and instead of getting kicked
out of class and going to see the
principal whenever you do something
wrong you gotta go outside and do
whatever exercise the sergeant gives you
until they get tired of looking at you
so
i was hard-headed i ended up doing a lot
of push-ups but i got it was
sucked at the time but it was fun
looking back i wish i could go back
to smooth out some of your rough edges
uh no it made it worse i got no fight
like the day before i was supposed to
[ __ ] uh graduate the program i ended
up getting into a fight right in the
middle of formation
uh it took like three sergeants to get
me off of them
that was fun
what is it about your
your makeup your personality that that
makes you so uh
is it defiant is that the word what are
you um
growing up i was told by therapists that
i have odd which is oppositional
defiance disorder meaning that mentally
if you tell me not to do something like
don't go and jump on the bed you'll
break your leg even if i know i'm not
gonna break even if i know i'm gonna
break my leg even if i know it's a bad
idea you told me not to so now i feel
like i'm inclined to want to do it more
and it was just it was hard growing up
but i've learned to deal with it a
little bit
it's still stubborn but it helps me
26 because now i'm on my own it's like
nobody can tell me what to do like
that's the reason i have a hard time in
shelters and stuff like that because
they keep putting rules and stipulations
and
this and that like
right now i'm not allowed to have more
than one bike where i'm at and like
there's a problem or i can't smoke where
i'm at so i put a [ __ ]
plastic bag and a rubber band around the
smoke detector and just sitting my room
in smoke because they told me i couldn't
oh you got housing now well no i got the
temporary housing it's like uh i don't
know if you've heard of them the tiny
home villages i've heard of it yeah i'm
in one of those so i got my own little
tiny room luckily for now anyway
i'm working on getting my housing i got
my voucher and all but uh they just keep
hitting me with the push off like they
keep telling me i'm waiting on my
[ __ ] voucher to be clear voucher
declared okay well why the [ __ ] can't i
hear anything i've heard you were on the
streets before that yeah i've been on
the street since i was 21.
i left south carolina because of a
warrant
well not a warrant uh investigator came
and
asked me if uh he asked me to come turn
myself in would i and hit me with a
search warrant and i didn't realize that
the search warrant was bogus because it
was supposed to have a name signature
where the judge's name was and instead
it said bond court judge word for word
so i asked my dad at the time i was like
hey you remember all the times you said
that you would buy me a ticket anywhere
in the u.s as long as you get me out of
your hair and i'd leave you alone he's
like yeah i was all if i asked you about
me a ticket to arizona will you tell the
police where i went and he told me write
a note that says you want me gone fine
i'm gone and he said that i was already
telling the police that i was filing
eviction papers on me so he said when
they come and ask for you i'll just go
in the house date it for a couple days
before come out hand it to him and say
hey this was on the counter when i got
home
i went to live with my sister for about
a month when i got to arizona until
i got kicked out for drinking and
choking out her stepson well not her
steps on her actual son like three four
times
and that's when i got on the street she
actually lied to me about that situation
because i lost my job and i was waiting
on my last check to come in the mail so
i knew that she was kicking me out and i
asked her well i know you're gonna kick
me out if you can wait until i get my
check in the mail that'd be awesome and
i'll leave on my own that way i can at
least get a hotel room i don't have to
start on the street and she's all yeah
no problem i think your mom's coming to
get you in the morning to come spend the
weekend with her so i'm like cool i pack
a bag for the weekend thinking i'm just
going with my mom for the weekend my mom
pops up the next morning and she's like
is that all you got
i'm on
what do you mean i'm just coming to
spend the weekend with you she said no
your sister's kicking you out she didn't
tell you because she was afraid of your
reaction
so from there i ended up packing all my
bags and leaving to a homeless shelter
from there and
i met my brother there but unfortunately
my brother's in a wheelchair now and i
can't really hang out with him because
he's at a hospital somewhere in downtown
that situation sucked he had gotten a
spot two spinal cord abscesses
which according to google they only get
two cases of those at about every ten
thousand hospital admissions
and now he can't you really feel or use
anything from the solar plex down
and he can't control his bladder and
he's been in a wheelchair for a little
bit over a year now he can like move his
legs or transfer himself from the chair
to the bed but that's about it
right and it's just hard on us right now
because we're trying to get him to
finish the situation he's in and
hopefully he heals but
it's just hard because i've been on the
street within shouting distance of my
brother for like four years and i just
it's different being on my own you know
what i mean like i'm not used to it and
it's just hard without them but
i manage you know i mean it's a little
bit harder and a little bit easier at
the same time
tell me about drug use uh drug use i
started as a kid because i was on
adderall when i was a kid
and then from there i graduated to stop
doing my adderall
and i started taking xanax hello pen
lortabs other pills stuff like that
then i started smoking weed there's one
time i actually [ __ ] crushed up a
lower tab oh which is a pain pill
i put it inside of a blunt and rolled it
up and then church the outside of the
blunt and liquid coating syrup and sat
there and smoked that [ __ ] with my
homies we were in the car faded
then i started drinking coding syrup
[ __ ] like that uh started drinking a
couple times but i don't really like
liquor because i get stomach hangovers
instead of head which is basically feels
like i got poison sitting on top of my
stomach for the whole next day and it
just makes me sick as hell
so that kind of ruined that for me but
from there i started doing [ __ ]
cocaine and
from cocaine i tried doing lsd shrooms
i've done ketamine i've done
research chemical uh
honestly i love acid i really wish i
knew where to find some right now but i
pretty much don't know where uh done
crystal i don't really consider weed a
drug
um
i've never done heroin fentanyl i don't
want to at all
i'm not so much into pills anymore since
i woke up in jail uh two days after my
birthday from xanax and didn't remember
still to this day don't remember eight
hours
of my life missing and there's days and
weeks out of my memory it's just gapped
because of xanax and i stopped doing
that but after i started doing that i
started doing crystal and it kind of got
worse and
now crystal's like an everyday thing i
gotta have it but
i don't really consider myself an addict
i consider myself a functioning user you
know what i mean because like
it sucks if i don't have it because i
feel like i don't have any energy like
even if i want to do something i can't
get up and go do it because i don't have
any energy
so it's kind of gotten to the point
where it's an everyday thing i gotta
have it to [ __ ]
get going to do my thing but it's also
currency it's one way i make money want
a mini you know how do you make money
now um now um
all kinds of different ways i mean i
know
how to take electricity from the city's
light poles and wire it to like a surge
protector and that way you got power in
your tent or
i know how to work on bikes or sell
bikes or steel bikes or trade bikes i've
sold drugs rob people uh
i mean really and truly if you can think
of it i've probably done it like this
situation for example
if people ask me do i know how to do
this like no but i figured out like
first time i ever had anything to do
with mechanics my homeboy came to me and
asked me if i knew how to fix a starter
in his ford f-150
i told him i'd never done it before but
i was willing to try i watched a video
on youtube and then i sat there and i
did it
like pretty much if i can figure out how
to do it i'm gonna do it but i prefer to
work with my hands and build stuff sit
like that
but easy money too like selling stuff if
i got it or sell it i just sold an ipod
or not an ipod a tablet that i found in
the trash uh
i just sold a piano well not a piano a
keyboard for 100 bucks that i found on
the side of the road
i
stole a bike off somebody's front porch
in [ __ ] uh santa monica like a week
ago and sold that for 50 bucks
whatever i get my hands on really i mean
if i can figure it out i mean might as
well make the money i'm down for
whatever as long as it's within reason
do you have friends
uh yeah i got a lot of friends well
nah i don't really consider them friends
i got family and i got associates and i
got enemies
these guys i don't really i mean i know
her a little bit you know she's a friend
a friend of the family and whatnot so
it's
i've known her for a little while but
not that much uh
i got people that i hang out with on a
daily basis and i got people that i
consider my brother
and like there's nothing i won't do for
them like they call me right now and
tell me we need to go spray somebody up
then we finna go spray somebody else
ain't no questions
and they just know at the end of the day
when it's all said and done
if i find out that they were the reason
that we had to do that and they weren't
wrong then i want my round with them but
i got your back until then you know what
i mean like if it's 12 on two then [ __ ]
let's get it let's beat the ass but if i
find out in the end that after we get no
weapon they ass or they don't open our
ass if i find out you're the reason that
this all started then you're going to
deal with me afterwards but
you know that's just how i work right
but i try not to fight that much because
i have the mentality of if i fight you
and i actually put my all into it and i
lose
now i feel like i'm obligated to fight
you and take flight on you every time i
see you until i win
and if i have that mentality then i have
the feeling that why wouldn't you have
that mentality and i haven't got time
for that i'd be way too high way too
much or coming down sometimes and
i ain't got time for that much drama and
[ __ ] like that and
so like i'm small like i'm not gonna try
and fight you i'm gonna pick something
up and i'm gonna hit you until i can't
until you stop [ __ ] moving
and that's just gonna be that at the end
of the day
friends i mean i got family i consider
them family street family
um i guess they started off as friends
but
i got a couple people that i associate
with but i don't really consider him a
friend because
in my opinion la is a very bad place and
it can be if you but it'll swallow you
up whole if you let it i started off in
venice and then the speech got worse i
ended up leaving venice beach about a
year ago around a couple days after
valentine's day i woke up one night
to some og trip hitting me in the mouth
and standing over me with a machete to
my throat
stole everything i own including my
violin dropped my bike on my head like
three times and then disappeared and i
ran and [ __ ] got the [ __ ] out of
venice
my brother was supposed to be out here
so i hopped on a bus and came out here
and found out he was in a hospital and
i've just been trying to [ __ ]
make it on my own since
every day is a new day every day is a
new struggle
i just try to move forward and never
look back
every day you start something new you
know what i mean like
if i can put i got the mentality of one
thing i've always said to myself growing
up is never accept defeat let alone
acknowledge what it means
so meaning that it doesn't matter how
bad you beat me down or it doesn't
matter how hard the job is or doesn't
matter how difficult the task is if i
can move i can crawl if i can crawl i
can walk if i can walk i can run in
other words as long as i'm breathing
there's nothing that's going to stop me
from doing what the [ __ ] i want to do if
i really want to do it i'm going to do
it period
you know and that's just kind of
mentality you have to have on the
streets because at the end of the day
on the streets i've come to learn that
you can never really rely on what
somebody else says
so like say for example let's just say
you say you're gonna pay me and i can't
count that money in my pocket until that
money is in my hand because you can
never count on somebody else for
something you can do for yourself
because you never know what might happen
what might come up what the situation
might be
and at the end of the day i know if
nobody else has my back i got my back
so i'm gonna make sure i eat i know i
got a drug habit so i know i'm gonna
make sure i got what i need to support
that habit i know i smoke cigarettes i
gotta have money to get cigarettes or a
way to get cigarettes i know i gotta
make sure i eat every day i know i gotta
make if nothing else i know me and i
know i'm the only one that's gonna
support my drugs i know i'm the only one
that's gonna support my cigarettes i
know i'm the only one that's gonna buy
me food
and i gotta make sure i do that so i try
to be on the grind every day and make as
much i try to make at least ten dollars
every day
it doesn't always work but it's just a
goal you know what i mean sometimes you
make more sometimes you make less
sometimes you don't make any
but as long as you have that goal in
mind i feel like there's always a way to
make money you just gotta find it
do you think your personality is just
not suited to things like
like conforming to things like school or
a nine-to-five job um honestly
i'm i've always thought and i've been
told that i'm very smart but i like
working with my hands i've been in
physical labor since i was 16 metal
fabrication shop
came out of military school started my
own pressure washing company started my
own landscaping company
going door-to-door cutting grass and
[ __ ] like that watching cars but
like out of everything i've done like i
just don't see myself sitting behind a
desk or a counter all day every day
because i got severe adhd like i can't
sit still that long for eight hours to
be able to do that like it's just not
gonna happen it's not who i am
but if you find me something that i find
interesting
then you're damn right i'm gonna do it
and what i find interesting is something
i'm good at which is working with my
hands you know i'm good at other stuff
but
some technology stuff from good at the
basics but technology is getting more
and more in advance and it escapes even
me and i don't really want to go back to
school because i don't really have the
attention span for it
and that's difficult originally i wanted
to go into the military but that didn't
work out the way i planned it and
now a lot of times it's actually kind of
difficult because i lost the tip of my
thumb
i had an abscess and i got worse and by
the time i went to the hospital
it became a deep space infection meaning
that they had to do surgery in order to
drain it rather than a lance and drain i
had an incision here here here with two
stitches
and
it never properly healed i didn't take
the antibiotics i didn't take care of it
the way it was supposed to
so for a while the bone was sticking out
with like a big ass scab over top of it
i remember when the thumbnail fell off
hell i remember when i was working on
bites with the bone was literally
sticking out of the tip of my thumb and
there was nothing but bone
and i was working on bites like this one
of the most painful things i've ever
felt is taking my [ __ ] bone on a bike
and one day i wiped out on my bike and
it snapped off
and it saved me a trip to the hospital
actually because if i got at that point
it was pretty much all healed except for
where the bone was sticking out and
there was no way i was going to get any
more flesh to go around that bone so it
was either i go to the hospital and they
saw the bone right there at the
beginning of the flesh so it can heal
over it
or it snapped off what you did and it
healed over and that's as much of my
thumb as i'll ever get back
so it's kind of hard to do like small
intricate things like i have a hard time
rolling blunts and joints and [ __ ]
but
you learn to cope with it you learn to
find a different way to do things but
for the most part i can't do like little
small things like working on things that
are real small i can't do it like it's
just i i can't do it i can't even
[ __ ] grab a cigarette out of my pack
with my this hand it's just too
difficult would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
um
tours that i would use to describe
myself self-destructive and clumsy
i'm very
i wouldn't necessarily say clumsy but
like
savage and flawed if that makes any
sense you know what i mean like
i don't really care what the deed is i'm
gonna go savage with it i'm gonna go 100
or i'm not gonna go at all
and i'm flawed because i feel like i got
a [ __ ] up sense of humor
at the same time i got a kind of a
[ __ ] up personality like
things that most people find [ __ ] up i
find hilarious and things that people
find hilarious i'm just sitting here
like really that that's stupid
i kind of have a dark mentality like
uh
i got a lot of things like unfortunately
my life was kind of hell when i was 18 i
had a daughter
and uh
well unfortunately my house got shot up
and it hit a gas line
i made it out my baby mama just barely
made it out
but for some reason she didn't grab our
daughter and my house exploded
because of that gas line and
i've
become [ __ ] up mentality-wise since
then because i don't feel like anybody
should have to really and surely bury
their child
let alone like me have nothing left to
bury of your child
for about a year i wouldn't i wouldn't
talk to anybody i wouldn't say [ __ ]
but after that i i think about suicide
every day but
uh only thing that really stops me is
two things one is i love to piss people
off and at the end of the day
i didn't put myself here it's gonna let
my haters win if i [ __ ] take myself
out so if i didn't put myself here why
am i gonna take myself out if it's gonna
[ __ ]
piss my haters off to be here then i
might as well be here rather than let
them win and take myself out plus
honestly i don't think that's what my
daughter would have wanted for me she
would have wanted me to [ __ ] you know
continue with my life and try and move
forward so i just keep her in my heart
and in my memories and just
try to move forward every day you know
it's hard but
you do what you got to do
you know everybody's got everybody's got
a story everybody's got baggage and
some is worse than others and at the end
of the day like
i just haven't been the same since that
happened you know like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] i think about all the
time and [ __ ] up [ __ ] is usually what
helps me but at the same time like
i have no remorse like i have a
conscience but i have no remorse so my
conscience tells me that i don't really
want to fight this dude but my no
remorse tells me that when i start
fighting okay
i don't give a [ __ ] about you as far as
i'm concerned in my mind you're trying
to kill me because i don't know what
you're gonna do if i get knocked out or
i hit the ground you might stomp me out
you might beat me down like so if i'm
thinking you're trying to kill me i'm
gonna take that personally and i'm gonna
take that to heart i'm gonna pick up
something and i'm gonna continuously
beat you with it until i'm satisfied or
you just stop moving
and that's why i feel like i'm [ __ ] up
because like
i don't give a [ __ ] like if it's not my
if it's not my family
then it's [ __ ] like i ain't got time
for them stay the [ __ ] out of my way
and this is how i've always been like
i don't care if you're in my way i will
move you you can move on your own or i
promise you your mama gonna wear a black
dress before mine do
because you're not gonna make my mama
cry like [ __ ] my parents didn't even
know about my child
and before i had the opportunity to tell
them that happened so
life's too short to sit here and worry
about the little things life's too short
to worry about anything
i'm just trying to get high and enjoy my
time you know while i can if you try to
stop me from that then you need to get
the [ __ ] out of the way because like i'm
trying to initiate quick i'm not trying
to drag it on and start beef and have a
rivalry you know i'm trying to [ __ ]
get you the [ __ ] out of my way eat you
the [ __ ] out of my face so i can
continue to get high and enjoy my time
i i'm not trying to start no beef i'm
just
want to feel free and do my own thing
and people got a problem with that then
it's [ __ ] them
what are you afraid of now in your life
spiders honestly
it sounds crazy but spiders
freak me out uh
i will literally run from them i used to
live in a tunnel and like it's not that
i'm afraid of the dark per se it's like
i'm my
how do i describe it my mind
plays tricks on me so when i'm in the
dark i swear i hear things or if i can't
see i think like somebody's coming it's
not that i'm afraid of the dark it's
afraid of what might be in the dark like
when i lived under a bridge in a tunnel
i was thinking every night that some
freaking maniac might come through on
[ __ ] high [ __ ] out of their mind on
sherm oh yeah that was fun i've done
sherm too
but um might come out high as hell out
of their mind and [ __ ] out of
murderings for you and just try to kill
me but
also i'm a juggalo which is a member of
follower of icp anybody that listens icp
is a juggalo and
you know like at the end of the day i
got family no matter what because i'll
always have juggalo family but things
that i'm scared of i refuse to be scared
of any one person
because if you bleed the same as me then
what do i got to be scared of if you can
bleed just as easy as i can
i'm not really scared of a gun because i
welcome death i embrace it it's the one
thing that everybody is guaranteed from
the day they are born no matter what you
do no matter what you accomplish you're
going to die one day it's the only thing
you have to do
but spiders stay i don't know i've never
seen black widows until i got to van
nuys california and now
every time i see one is bigger than the
last one the last one i seen was about
the size of a 50 cent piece without its
legs
its hourglass was like the size of a
quarter and
that's a big enough spider to where i
promise you if i saw that in my tent i
would literally grab my bag my phone
no i won't even grab my bag i grab my
phone on my bike and i'll be like yeah
you can have this tent and i'm leaving
i'd never come back to it
like ever
like it's big enough to where i wouldn't
even [ __ ] with it i just moved like
period
but that's probably the only thing that
scares me i love heights i think better
when i'm on high up on heights uh
i love adrenaline i've always loved
adrenaline
um
i kind of get
i don't know i mean i kind of am scared
of i guess it would be like the angel of
death per se like you ever been driving
down the road and you swerve because you
swear you saw like a shadow or something
crossing the street and then you look
back and it wasn't there
and i just feel like
that shadow that ghost is following you
but it's weird because i don't really
believe in ghosts i believe in aliens
because i mean
you if you ever heard of string theory
there's three parts of string theory
which is open closed and straight
which means that open is the universe
started from the big bang
and it created the whole universe and
the universe is constantly expanding
and the close is the universe started
from big bang and when it exploded it
went to as big as it'll ever get and
it's constantly shrinking from there
until it all gets one central point and
it starts over
and then straight is from the big bang
this is the biggest it's ever been as
big as it's ever going to be as big as
it'll ever get
and with that either way you're telling
me if the earth was even a
100 percentile of a difference in the
atmosphere wouldn't be sustainable for
life
and that just so happened to [ __ ] be
random out of choice no i believe in
aliens and i believe like
all of the bibles and religions and [ __ ]
that uh happen like
uh aztecs like the greeks the uh romans
the uh
egyptians like they all actually have a
pattern like uh christianity has the
holy trinity god the father and the holy
spirit
or i mean the father the son of the holy
spirit then you look at uh
greeks they got
uh
zeus poseidon and hades they look at the
[ __ ] uh
romans they got pluto they got jupiter
they got neptune you look at
egyptians they got raw they got set they
got horus
and the weird thing is i believe that
they all happened
but not to the degree we believe
i believe that they happened but the
degree that they came is the human race
was then and is still now so
unintelligent
and stuff like that to where
if you've ever seen star wars and you're
telling me if that was a long long time
ago in a galaxy far far away and they
have technology like that they can cloak
ships
well why can't they cloak or [ __ ]
turn themselves into something else and
walk among us like we don't even know
they exist
or they might look just like us and at
the end of the day like i believe that
these beings these guides really existed
all of them but they were aliens like
for example most people know as
pterodactyls pterodactyls is also is
actually the breed the species itself is
known as pero pero
and
the reason i bring that up is because
scientists lately have been thinking
that a lot of the dinosaurs might have
not been reptilian they might have
actually been feathered
some of them
so if that's the case
quetzalcoatl is the uh
aztec deity that was known as a large
giant feathered serpent with wings
well out of pterodactyls the largest of
all the breeds of pterodactyls was
actually called quetzalcoatl
which would have at the time
being a
possibly a giant snake with wings that
possibly was feathered
and i don't think that's a coincidence i
really think that these beings existed
we just believed that they were gods
because of the things they could do and
i believe there's a heaven or a hell but
i don't believe there's a god and a
devil there's something that created us
but i don't know what
and i don't know i just look forward to
finding out one day if it is god i got a
couple questions i really want to ask
him
do you have any regrets
um regrets
honestly and truly
no because
everything that's happened in my life
whether it been good or [ __ ] up like i
used to regret not finishing high school
but then i thought about it if i would
have never if i would have finished high
school
i would have never left south carolina i
would have never been here
and at the end of the day i believe
i shouldn't have any regrets because
everything i've done had led up to who
i've become to this day
you know i've become i personally
believe i've become a lot better of a
man
than what i was four years ago and i'm
grateful for every experience that i've
been through for that i'm grateful for
every ass whooping that's taught me a
lesson i'm grateful for everything
i just
my only regret is that i haven't bought
a violin by now because since i got
robbed for the first one i've been
wanting another one ever since and
i just miss my music that's about it but
i try not to have regrets it's better
that way
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
most important lesson i've learned in my
life um
i've learned a lot of lessons
and i've learned a lot of different ways
i'd probably say
like some of the most important ones is
like i said never give up never accept
defeat
um
never quit
you know never back down at the same
time
i would also say like
know what you're getting yourself into
no matter what
you know like prepare i'd say the best
lesson would probably be
prepare for the worst hope for the best
no matter what happens you're ready
you know and i used to know that when i
was going to work as a hood cleaner we'd
go into restaurants after hours and we'd
clean the grease out of the hoods above
the grills and [ __ ] and
you know with some of those like asians
they would get to the point where like
asian restaurants you're supposed to
have them cleaned every four months well
these guys would have them wait like
almost a year or two until the fire
marshal was ready to shut them down if
they didn't get it clean and then we'd
have to go in there and it would take
all [ __ ] night
and you know like
pretty much it's just one of the things
like
you just gotta watch your surroundings
and know who you're around and
one thing i've learned in l.a probably
the most important lesson i've learned
in l.a is that
anytime you meet somebody you have a
split second to this uh to
decipher between friend or foe
immediately like you don't have time to
get to know them you don't have time to
say hey how are you is literally that hi
i'm better than uh and from that moment
from the moment you open your mouth and
they open your mouth you have to be able
to decide friend or foe because it could
be your life right there in l.a somebody
could rob you kill you right then and
there or they could be your best friend
and bless you with millions of dollars
but you have to be able to discern the
difference between the two
and that's probably like the best lesson
i've learned in a long time i'm still
learning is
it's hard to learn people but
knowing who you're around and knowing
trying to see people's true self and
true personality is probably the most
important part
and i'd say that's probably one of the
most important lessons i've learned
along with never quitting
because as long as you never quit you
i mean in the south we got a saying a
man with a truck can always make money
we say that because if you got a truck
there's always a way to make money
somebody might have you haul off their
trash somebody might need you to haul
this tow this do that
but either way like
you know you always have to have
yourself open and have a way to make
money no matter what your situation is
and
just
my most important lessons are never quit
always be prepared to make money and
always know friend from foe and be able
to tell the difference really quick
because your life might depend on it
all right okay thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah i wish you the
best of luck out there same to you thank
you so much for taking my time thank you
you